Brush like a Pro.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FBI SPYING IN THE
2016 ELECTION COULD BE EVEN MORE
FAR-REACHING THAN WE EVEN KNEW.
THIS TRIPADVISOR SAYS THAT
IN 2016, HE AND ROGER STONE WERE
APPROACHED BY A MAN UNDER THE
ALIAS HENRY GREENBERG WHO ASKED
FOR $2 MILLION IN EXCHANGE FOR
DIRT ON HILLARY CLINTON.
GREENBERG, DOCUMENTS INDICATE,
HAS WORKED AS AN FBI INFORMANT
OVER THE SPAN OF 17 YEARS.
HE THINKS HE MAY HAVE BEEN
INFORMING WHEN HE APPROACHED THE
CAMPAIGN.
MICHAEL JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE STORIES
THAT PENALIZING, BECAUSE THE
FACTS THAT WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN,
OR SEEM TO KNOW FOR CERTAIN, IT
SEEMED TO GO TO THE FBI.
HE LISTED THE FBI AND AN FBI
AGENT ON AN FBI APPLICATION.
HE CLEARLY WAS WORKING IN SOME
FACET FOR THE FBI.
>> HE WAS.
RIGHT.
WE DO.
WHEN I WAS INTERVIEWED BY THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION ON
MAY 2ND, I EXPOSED OR ANSWERED
ABOUT THIS GREENBERG APPROACH IN
RESPONSE TO A PERJURY TRAP.
THAT REALLY ANGERED MY
INTERVIEWER, AND HIS EMOTIONAL
RESPONSE WAS A RED FLAG TO ME.
THEY SEEM TO KNOW MORE ABOUT IT
THAN I DID.
WHEN I GOT OUT OF MY MUELLER
INVESTIGATION INTERVIEW, MICHAEL
FIND ME FOR MY LEGAL FUND WENT
THROUGH THE ROOF, AND I USED
SOME OF THOSE FUNDS TO HIRE
INVESTIGATORS FIND OUT MORE
ABOUT HENRY GREENBERG.
WE QUICKLY FOUND OUT THROUGH AN
IMMIGRATION AND NATURALIZATION
SERVICE FILING THAT HE MADE IN
2015 THAT HE SIGNED UNDER OATH
SAYING HE WAS AN FBI INFORMANT
FOR 17 YEARS.
ALSO HERE IN IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA, AND HE PROVIDED 14
DIFFERENT FBI INFORMANT VISAS AS
PROOF OF THAT.
I QUICKLY DUG INTO EVERY ASPECT
OF HIS LIFE.
YOU CAN SEE ALL OF IT AT
Democrat.ca.ORG.
HE HAS BEEN IN JAIL TEN YEARS IN
RUSSIA, COMMITTED ASSAULT WITH A
DEADLY WEAPON, AND BEFORE THE
FBI HAD THROWN HIM OUT OF THE
COUNTRY, DEPORTED HIM INTO
THOUSAND ZERO, BUT SOMEHOW IT IS
BACK AND HE HAS BEEN LIVING
UNDER FBI VISAS.
THE QUESTION ISN'T, WAS HE AN
FBI INFORMANT.
THE QUESTION IS, DID HE TAKE
TIME OFF FROM HIS LONG CAREER AS
AN FBI INFORMANT TO HAVE LUNCH
OFF THE CLOCK AND MADE ROGER
STONE.
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
ONLY HERE BECAUSE HE WAS WORKING
FOR THE FBI.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD HAVE
DEPORTED HIM AGAIN.
>> Tucker: THIS WOULD BE, IF
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS TRUE,
THIS WOULD BE THE SECOND
VERIFIED INSTANT OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S FBI SPYING ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HOW CAN YOU FIND OUT IF THAT IS
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
>> A FEW DIFFERENT THINGS.
IT COULD BE PROOF THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BEGAN TWO MONTHS
EARLIER THAN THEY ARE ADMITTING
TO RIGHT NOW.
AS EARLY AS MAY INSTEAD OF JULY.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
INVESTIGATION HAS EMBOLDENED
INVESTIGATORS FROM CONGRESS, WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS VERY EASY FOR
THEM IF THEY CAN GET DOCUMENTS
OUT OF THE DOJ TO FIND OUT IF
HENRY GREENBERG, WHO GOES BY
MANY OTHER NAMES, IF HE WAS
UNDER ANOTHER FBI AND THE OTHER